so inside the fume hood we've got a
liter beaker and there's a dark solution
in there I'll put the lights on
temporarily just so you can see kind of
a ready brown color there and we've got
inside thermocouple beading about
twenty-five point five degrees C so
there's a reason why that thermocouple
was there and there's a reason why we're
going to turn the light off
I will be adding to this solution 30
mils of concentrated hydrogen peroxide
so this is going to go in and we can
watch what happens
whoa oh that's cool oh that's so cool oh
my god that's so cool
the temperatures currently 94.3 and
climbing
that was an extremely violent reaction
and now it's kind of gone is 96.3 still
climbing and it's gone yellow so started
out as if nothing had happened so we
added the hind room peroxide in and it
looked like there was a several second
delay and I honestly thought the
reaction had failed but actually it's
it's a it's a delay on purpose is what's
known as a clock reaction it takes time
for the reaction to actually happen but
when it did it was extremely exothermic
so a lot of heat was produced
he saw the foam there and addition to
some foaming which then rapidly roasts
the top of the beaker
there was actually chemiluminescence
there as well so to that solution was
added a very small amount of luminol and
that's what happened towards the end of
the reaction was those actually the
traditional luminol that you would have
seen in our previous videos and in
thunder and lightning lectures yeah it's
still calling down now to about 80 but
with gloves on yeah the glasses is
really really hot strong reaction
with a nice color change or acid which
was nice clear color or no color is now
almost black